Rick how you feeling well I'm a little
wounded right now then the last time I
came on your show the first thing you
talked about was flushing something why
do I remind you of a toilet what's
what's up with that and I sorry I it's
just a subliminal thought there on your
part there don't mean any harm but he
doing great great great to be with you
will I will I see you in Chicago well I
didn't make plans for it but I'd like to
go I just don't know how crazy it is
since I I work on sunday on football
night in America but I'd like to like to
come come in for game 3 for fridays and
I promise you you'll be thinking of your
karaoke songs to play at murphys after
the game but that night that's that's
our go-to now the hockey pucks chelios
and those guys they rig some machine up
and it's a lot of fun Joe Buck did it so
there's no reason you can't you can't
think of something to come up with uh
how many ticket request of you got oh
well one that I've returned probably 40
I don't know that I'm gonna be able to
help all of them but we're gonna get as
many of them in as we can forget Mr
Barclay will be there got a call from my
good buddy Kix Brooks you know Eddie
will be there that will be there yeah
it's going to be it's going to be it's
gonna be a lot of fun I can't think of
anything I've done it's gonna be more
fun and that than what this series will
be it feels like we're supposed to be
rooting for the Cubs that America is
supposed to be if you don't have any you
know team in this if you're not an
Indian defending your supposed to root
for the Cubs the Indians pretty good
story here and you be in a former Indian
yourself how big a story is this from
the Cleveland perspective well then as
you know I you know I played a couple of
years there before being traded to the
Cubs I know what it was like then I no
difficulty was I know it was like before
the new ballpark but the thing to me as
I look back the boston red sox were a
lot better man perm and Anthony Indians
were I
did the Toronto and Texas series I saw
how Toronto just manhandled the Texas
Rangers and I felt like they were much
better team than Cleveland it's this
chemistry it's this connector that they
talk about with literary Francona no
difference in what he did in Boston I
thought he had more ability in Boston
but you know that that platoon thing
that they talk about where they mapped
out you know how you put together a
lineup and how you use your bullpen gee
far and away ran away with the best
numbers in baseball putting people in a
chance in a situation where they have a
chance to be successful I mean it's just
been the magic of him that's gotten them
this far I've been on paper I think most
people would say the Cubs are better but
do not ever you know count-out or Terry
Francona team but also you know we we
have this lovable loser label with the
cubs and I I said this yesterday I said
the cub fans I know never embrace that
it's not I mean what else were they
going to do they went to the games
therefore they must be lovable losers
because they're supporting a team that's
not any good you played there you're
attached to that city are they lovable
losers were they level Baloo zor's I
don't think so i think that's something
then it may be just a media made up
you're exactly right I was never around
a player that felt that way we had a
couple of opportunities in 84 and 89 it
got away from us and I was talking to
somebody the other day about you know
does this team feel the pressure of a
hundred and eight years no they told
I'll tell you right now if you walked up
and that asked Addison Russell if I ever
played the game he wouldn't know okay he
doesn't know do you think about Kris
Bryant okay the three years before he
got there they finished in dead last in
their division they've been this
disguise done nothing but win throughout
his whole life he gets there they
playing the national league championship
his first year in the big league they're
playing in the World Series this year
even you had nothing to do with 107
years he's had everything to do with
turn this franchise around and giving
them as we all know an opportunity to
win for a long long time talking to Rick
Sutcliffe for the
ship joining us I saw a column I think
it was over the weekend it said that you
know be careful what you ask for Cub
fans you might lose your identity if you
win a World Series what do you make of
that don't you want to lose your
identity you know you know then what I
think of and I'm sure it simple in the
past I've told you the story but we
clinched in 84 in Pittsburgh they hadn't
been to the playoffs in 39 years we come
back from that road trip we get to the
clubhouse that morning and Ernie Banks
Billy Williams Fergie Jenkins Ron Santo
were in the clubhouse okay yeah I knew I
knew a lot of them were but Ron Santo
came up to me and he grabbed me by my
shirt collar and I mean to the point
where I couldn't get away and he looked
at me and he had tears in his eyes and
he goes I'll never be able to thank you
thank you for helping these fans forget
about what happened in nineteen
sixty-nine now then I at that point I
had no clue I couldn't know about a
black cat I didn't know anything I I you
know I knew brunch Santa's name I never
met him before I didn't know that was
him until somebody later and told me I
hope at some point this year next year
whatever I hope at some point to be able
to walk up to Theo Epstein and do the
same thing to help people forget about
you know the disappointments yeah we had
a great time during the summer of 80 49
but we fell short I hope to be able to
do that sometime so i don't feel like
the identity or lovable loser or
anything like that is in the equation i
think it's a matter of just getting this
over with and I'm sure the people of
Cleveland feel the same way it's been a
long time for them which manager would
you want to pitch for I know Terry as a
teammate I know him as a friend is one
of the funnier guys I've ever been
around I've never been around anybody in
baseball smarter than Joe man he has
just did things in Tampa that were so
far ahead of the curve that you know him
and Zimmer that came up with that safety
squeeze and then all of a sudden after
they pulled it on st. Louis last year
and won a playoff game you know his
first emphasis in spring training was on
how to defend it and he came up with a
for that no one that teams were gonna
throw it at it I gotta be honest with
you I you know I got to know to go real
well back when he was managing Boston we
through doing the games for MLB
international I you know I spent a lot
of october's with him but I'm not been
in uniform with terry francona other
than as a teammate you know the last you
know couple of years I've been in
uniform said steel been there with the
Cubs but the last two years I've been
there every day of spring training with
the cubs and just watching how out Joe
Maddon just how he connects with players
now he you know he wants to know
everything about you so that he knows
you know what he can do to get the best
out of you what if the Cubs don't win um
I think I think back to something
Larry's of kino told me a long time ago
when he was with the Padres he said the
one that got me into broadcasting on
baseball and he said I considered a good
year when we're in contention on my
birthday and his birthday was set to sep
tember first and I I think it'll still
be looked at as a great year anybody
that's been there for you know they
asked me to come back and throw out the
first pitch of Game one of the league
championship against the Dodgers after
walking out of the ballpark that night I
mean just the great feeling that they
have there's a sense of pride they have
filled in their fans and in that city
yeah it's going to be a disappointment I
mean it hurts more to get to this point
lose and it does to be out of it you
know in the middle of August but I you
know it's just it's hard for me to look
at it that way because this gene is
played so well all year long I mean it's
just a matter of putting it together
four more games and it's going to be
exciting to see which can do that before
I let you go aside from the obvious give
me your sneaky most valuable player
whether he's named that or not but this
guy could be a difference maker all
right i'll give you the one I'm pulling
for and that's council over I mean you
know we've had a tad eh who's been a
most valuable player Matsui gia did that
for the Yankees
few years ago um this this is this is
Barry Bonds this I mean literally I
don't know this feels never told me I've
heard a rumor that they could have had
Andrew Miller for if they wanted to give
up short book this is one of the best
young kids that I've ever been around
and offensively I ever been Barry Bonds
I've never seen a better swing I'm you
know I know what rehabs like I've been
through it in you've done it with your
needs a couple times you know how hard
that work is to get in I'm really
pulling for him to be able to be in the
lineup and to maybe do something to help
the Cubs Greg talk to you safe travels
as always and uh have fun I'll see you
Friday ready ya see read the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience